Traductor: Alessandra Mantellini
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Día tras día, los hermanos gemelos,
Jun y Wuqub,
corrían de un lado a otro
jugando a la pelota.
Un día, su vigoroso juego
perturbó a los dioses del inframundo,
quienes desafiaron a los gemelos
a un partido.
Cuando los hermanos llegaron,
los dioses los atraparon y los mataron,
colgando la cabeza de Jun
de un árbol, como un trofeo.
El árbol pronto produjo muchos frutos,
lo que llamó la atención
de una de las hijas de los dioses.
Cuando ella agarró un fruto,
el cráneo de Jun escupió en su mano
y la embarazó.
Huyendo de la ira de su padre,
se refugió con su suegra
y dio a luz a gemelos:
Junajpu e Ixb’alanke.
La segunda generación de gemelos
descubrió el juego de pelota de su padre,
que su abuela había escondido,
y empezaron a jugar.
Muy pronto,
los mensajeros del inframundo
llegaron para emitir otro desafío.
Aun sabiendo lo que les había pasado
a sus padres,
los gemelos respondieron a la llamada,
atravesando cavernas profundas
y cruzando ríos
llenos de escorpiones, sangre y pus,
hasta que llegaron a la gran ciudad,
donde los dioses del inframundo
controlaban cada aspecto de la naturaleza
y les causaban sufrimiento a los humanos.
Los gemelos siguieron buscando
a los dioses que los habían desafiado.
Los dioses se escondieron entre estatuas
para confundir a sus invitados,
pero los hermanos enviaron a un mosquito
por adelantado.
Cuando picaba a las estatuas,
los dioses gritaban, revelándose.
Obligaron a los gemelos a pasar la noche
en la Casa de las Tinieblas.
Les dieron una antorcha
que debían encender sin fuego o morirían.
Mientras oscurecía,
los inteligentes hermanos
adornaron la antorcha
con plumas de guacamayo rojo
y luciérnagas.
Por la mañana, los dioses se sorprendieron
al ver la antorcha encendida sin fuego.
Insistieron en jugar con su propia pelota.
Los gemelos estuvieron de acuerdo,
pero los dioses habían escondido un arma
dentro de la pelota,
que los persiguió por la cancha,
tratando de matarlos.
Los gemelos sobrevivieron
a esa primera ronda,
pero a estas alturas estaban seguros
de que este no sería un partido normal.
Jugaron muchas más rondas,
y cada vez
los gemelos no hacían más que empatar,
haciendo que se enfrentaran
a cualquier prueba sobrenatural
que los dioses escogieran para ellos
antes de retomar el juego.
Sobrevivieron a la Casa del Frío
encendiendo un fuego,
y la Casa de los Jaguares
alimentando a las bestias con huesos.
Pero en la Casa de los Murciélagos,
uno le arrancó la cabeza a Junajpu.
Seguros de que ahora tenían la ventaja,
los dioses pidieron otra ronda
del juego de la pelota,
exhibiendo la cabeza de Junajpu
en la cancha.
El inteligente Ixb’alanke
llamó a los animales.
Una tortuga le trajo un chilacayote,
y él lo talló a semejanza
de una cabeza.
Los dioses corrían tras la pelota
mientras él lo intercambió con la cabeza.
Con la cabeza de Junajpu sobre su cuerpo,
los gemelos jugaron mejor que nunca.
Finalmente, ganaron el juego
y golpearon la calabaza colgante,
por lo que se hizo añicos en el suelo.
Los gemelos sabían que sus anfitriones
no serían buenos perdedores.
Para protegerse,
reclutaron a un par de espectadores.
Efectivamente, los dioses
cocinaron a los hermanos en un horno,
pero los espectadores se aseguraron
de que sus restos fueran arrojados al río,
que les devolvió la vida.
Los gemelos se presentaron ante los dioses
disfrazados de dos niños desaliñados
y comenzaron a bailar y a hacer milagros.
Para su último truco,
Ixb’alanke fingió matar a Junajpu,
y luego lo resucitó.
Los dioses estaban tan encantados
que exigieron
que se les hiciera el mismo truco.
Aún disfrazados, los hermanos
estaban encantados de complacerlos,
y comenzaron a matar a los dioses,
uno por uno.
Cuando los dioses supervivientes
se dieron cuenta de quiénes eran ellos
y de que no habría ninguna resurrección,
suplicaron piedad,
y los gemelos los maldijeron.
De ahora en adelante,
los dioses no tendrían sacrificios
ni poder alguno
sobre el mundo de la superficie.
Sus días aterrorizando a los humanos
se habían acabado.